-Thank you for being here.
How great does that look when
you come out and see all the --
-Hot.
-Yeah, hot is exactly right.
Exactly right.
We got a lot to talk about.
Since I last saw you, you got
engaged to the lovely Megan Fox.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's great.
-Also, your latest album,
"Mainstream Sellout," came out
in March and went right
to number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not too shabby, bud.
-Thank you.
-Number one, not too shabby.
And on June 8th, you're going to
kick off a global tour.
Global. This is your first
big arena tour.
Venues sold out in a day,
by the way.
Dude, you couldn't be hotter
right now.
-You're stroking my ego.
-Sorry about that. I apologize.
What are the shows gonna be like
when you do the arena tours?
-You know how, like, shows have
big LED screens
and all that stuff?
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
-Yeah, we scratched all that.
We're like, "A good showman
just needs a show."
-But you've played kind of
every venue out there.
-Dude, I can tell you Wi-Fi
codes to like bars
in Blackfoot, Idaho.
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, you have
those Wi-Fi codes.
-I can tell you the door code to
some of these venues.
-So you've seen it all.
-Yeah, all of them.
Except the arenas,
so I'm excited.
-Yeah. I was gonna say.
You know what? There's a quote
that I'm sure you heard this.
But I just have to tell you that
Mick Jagger said something about
you recently.
Can I read it to you?
-Please.
-"In rock music --"
[ as Mick Jagger ] In rock
music, you need energy.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
"You need energy,
and there have not been a lot of
new rock singers around.
Now, there are a few.
You have Yungblud
and Machine Gun Kelly.
That kind of post-punk vibe
makes me think
there still is a bit of life
to rock 'n' roll."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mick Jagger!
-Alright!
-Mick Jagger!
-Yeah.
-How does that feel?
Did you -- When did you hear
that he said that?
-On a bad day.
-That's a good day to hear it.
-Absolutely.
It was like -- It was a day --
I'm polarizing to people
for some reason,
so there was a lot of -- Like,
you can just feel a lot of hate
coming at you sometimes,
and I just remember, like,
I was feeling it that morning,
and then I read that quote
and then I just said...
"I didn't say it."
[ Laughter ]
-"I didn't say it.
Yeah, he said it, not me."
That's got to make you feel
fantastic.
-Yeah, it was great.
-Have you ever met Mick Jagger?
-No, but it would be hard for me
to be across from him
and not do this.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And just do it.
'Cause you want to start doing
the rooster with him?
-I might.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You have to kind of do it
when you see him.
♪♪
Yeah, that's the way -- Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about!
You got to do that.
Congrats on "Good Mourning."
It's in select theaters
and on demand now.
Mourning, by the way,
is spelled M-O-U-R.
-Yes.
-Yeah, "Good Mourning."
It's a comedy that you wrote
based on a text
that you got from a girlfriend?
-From Megan.
-From Megan?
-Yes.
-Oh.
-I'm a one-woman man.
-Of course you are, yeah.
So, you got a text from Megan
and so it just -- What happened?
You spiraled out?
-Yeah, it's like -- it started
with, like, Megan's
very just in nature.
She's like -- That's where
her head's always at.
The text -- It was this long
paragraph that started with
like, "A raven came and sat next
to me in a tree."
And then, you know,
it was all this stuff.
And then she got on a plane
and went to Europe
and didn't take her phone and I
was just like, "What is that?"
Like, "You can't leave me
with this."
And it was right when I was --
when we were starting to,
like, be serious.
I just like took the message
to all my friends
who aren't in relationships
for relationship advice,
which is, like, great,
and they were like,
"That's not good, dude."
[ Laughter ]
And now, after doing all this
press for the movie, I'm like,
"Why did I write --" Like,
instead of just waiting
to talk about it, I like, got
manic and wrote a whole movie
and got all this cast involved
and spent the studio's money.
And I'm just like,
"I should have just
waited a week and talked."
-Yeah, and talked to her, yeah.
But you turned out
with a great product.
When you do these movies,
it's a big deal.
You also play it in front of
audiences, like test audiences.
And you were telling me there's
a couple things that got cut
from this movie
that were high-budget things.
Big-budget stuff.
I mean, like -- Yeah.
What were they, like, CGI?
-No, no. We were like,
"Let's just go real."
So, we had a $50,000 lobster --
[ Laughs ]
We spent $50,000 between this
lobster and an electric eel.
-You spent $50,000
on this lobster puppet?
[ Laughter ]
-Is there a picture of the eel?
But it might have gone to
the LED lights that are put in.
None of which, either of these
make an appearance in the movie.
They all got cut because we,
like, screened it
and they had like
a 15-minute section
'cause we thought
it was so funny.
We were like, "Oh, this lobster
section is going to crush."
And it did the opposite.
Everyone left with -- The only
note pretty much for the whole
screening was like,
"Great, laughed my ass off.
Why was there this lobster scene
that was 15 minutes?
Like, what -- I hated it."
-Where is the puppet now?
-We don't know.
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
We probably need our money back.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like I've seen five of
these backstage in your show.
-Yeah, we make them.
We don't have $50,000
lobster puppets.
-It was for puppeteer costs too.
-Wowzers!
-We were super meticulous like,
"We need its claws to move.
We need its mouth to move."
We gave it abs.
[ Laughter ]
-Abs. I mean -- Well, it's
getting its play tonight.
-There we go.
That's almost kind of worth it.
-Your character is trying to get
an audition
for the role of Batman
in this movie.
-Yeah.
-Did you know that "The Batman"
was coming out
when you were writing this?
-No. It was just,
like, very serendipitous.
It just worked out like that.
It's a crazy story, because
Batman -- Batman and the entity
just kept popping up because,
you know, "Batman" came out
a month before
this movie came out.
And we were like, "Oh, my God,
that's great. This is crazy."
And then also a month ago I was
having my birthday party,
and you know, there was this one
Easter where I was like,
"Hey, Pete, you got to come.
You know, let's go to
my friend's house for Easter."
He pulled up and he had 40s
and he was like,
"Let's do this thing."
And we went and it was
Sandra Bullock's house.
We walked in. It was Jen Aniston
and all these, like --
And Pete was like,
"Why would you do this to me?
We look so stupid.
We have 40 ounces
and we're at Sandra Bullock's.
Why didn't you tell me this is
where we were going?"
-America's sweetheart.
-So, it's like my birthday
last month. And he texts me.
He's like, "Hey, I'm about to
come to your party.
Can I bring a plus-one?"
I was like, "Yeah, of course."
And he pulls up and his plus-one
is Robert Pattinson.
And I was like,
"You brought Batman?"
[ Laughter ]
-Surprise!
-Yeah, it's so funny.
Everyone just kept coming up
like, "Dude, is Batman
at your birthday party?
It's funny when you become
Batman because no one
refers to you anymore as your
actual name. You're just Batman.
-Yeah, for the rest of
your life, you're Batman.
-You're Batman.
-Yeah.
Did you know Robert before?
-Yeah, again, always just out,
seeing him and stuff like that.
But this was a -- it's just --
But now he's Batman.
So I'm just like,
"What up, dude?
I know we know each other,
but you're kind of Batman now."
-Now you're Batman, yeah.
Can we set up the film
for anyone that wants to
know more about the film?
-No.
I'm just kidding.
No one go see it.
-It's a comedy. It's a comedy.
-It's a comedy, yes.
It kind of just goes back to the
classic days of, like, gag humor
and like, just, you know,
$50,000 lobster puppets
that we thought
were going to crush.
The cast is oddly great.
The budget was this big
and the cast is this big.
-Snoop Dogg is the voice
of a talking joint.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Not too shabby. I mean, you kind
of hit a home run there.
[ Applause ]
Hit a home run right there.
That's all you need. That's all
you need to really say.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Colson Baker
in "Good Mourning."
Take a look at this.
-Leo?
What the [bleep]
did you just do?
-London, what is this dust?
-That's not dust.
That's people, man.
-Homey, did you just bring
the dead grandma vase?
-Oh!
-We can fix this.
I think that was actually the
cousin that no one really liked.
So...we got to pick him up.
-Whoa, I ain't [bleep]
human remains, man.
-Dude, Leo.
You did it.
-It's all good. It's all good.
At least it was
just one of 'em.
I mean, it doesn't even look
that bad, guys.
[ Applause ]
-That's exactly right.
Colson Baker, a.k.a.
Machine Gun Kelly, everybody.
"Good Mourning" is in select
theaters and on demand now.
Catch him on tour this summer.